Kyle asks what's an area of life that
you haven't given your fullest efforts
great question you know and I probably
was willing to answer it because of how
good I feel about this question there
were two places 36 months ago that I was
struggling and one was kind of the
nonprofit NGO I was giving my dollars
but I wasn't giving my time now a very
proud member of the board of pencils of
promise and have gotten more involved my
time which is the real asset and I feel
like I'm checking that box of giving
back outside of my own and family and
things of that nature and so I feel good
about that and the other one is my
health so i would say health was the
clear answer only 35 days ago i guess
now maybe a little bit more Gary time
you know between kids and the businesses
and now working out and like you know
AJ's been pushing me this you know he's
got into golf a little bit like oh you
know I'm I don't feel like I've been
able to figure out or crack or hack Gary
time right I guess the Jets do that but
then that's really September to December
I get that Sunday four five seven eight
nine hours depending if it's a homer
road game i think january through
September finding something that just
for me that I really enjoy is something
I should probably figure out but the
truth is that doesn't feel right to me
right now is the kids are two and five I
want to kind of allocate to that the
health I'm just prioritizing other stuff
hopefully next two or three years Gary
time